let's be honest the trouble the trouble
all started when women were allowed to
vote
[Music]
[Music]
view the dramatic orchestral music and
pour yourself a drink because now you
too
can play the most important game at the
daily wire
yes or no
finally you will be able to put your
knowledge of your friends and family to
the test and bring home the game for
which i still don't really understand
the rules
available this fall you can pre-order
your game right now over in my
collection at dailywire.com
shop welcome back to another exciting
episode of yes or no
this time on the show we have one of my
absolute favorite protestants in america
and one of my favorite people broadly in
political media that would be ali beth
stuckey ally thank you for making the
track and coming on the show yeah thanks
for having me
we have your drink a very uh dainty and
grace graceful glass of prosecco
we've got my
typical martini yes we have a stack of
questions
ladies first
okay
christian movies suck it should never be
promoted on conservative platforms it
makes us look bad
i'm really tempted even to change my
answer because my producer is a fairly
well-known actor in christian movies
makes me lean in one direction okay so
you say
you're going to have to drink my dear
i'm going to have to drink i love
christian movies oh you do i like good
christian movies i mean one of the
greatest movies ever made passion of the
christ yes see that's what i was
thinking too and so you are correct
about my answer there are some really
cheesy christian movies yes but to say
that they should never be put on
conservative platforms i would say
that's a little too far even the cheesy
ones even the cheesy ones because you
never know what did paul say whether by
pretends or by truth at least the gospel
is proclaimed so whether by cheesiness
or by truth at least the gospel is
proclaimed right plus by the way that's
an excellent point and by the way
this is true in secular media too
there's plenty of schlock and cheesiness
in secular media if you got rid of
schlock and cheesiness lifetime and
hallmark would cease to exist but
sometimes you kind of want one of those
movies don't you exactly have i outed
myself as a lifetime movie watcher i
don't know yeah maybe so uh okay so i
have to drink a little bit as a
gentleman i'll drink in solidarity okay
thank you
okay got it next question
broadcasting big booty latinas is
helpful for the conservative movement
i believe this refers to
now his name escapes me but uh sort of
alex stein alex stein yeah alex stein
had this whole thing where he was
harassing aoc on the steps and
whether it was funny or not the question
is appropriate okay
oh
now based on what you said i might
change my answer
okay i'm gonna go
with
no
you're right i opposed it i didn't you
know it was funny it was funny and her
initial reaction was also funny and sort
of charming and if she just left it at
that that would be fine because he was
yelling at her and saying like you're
really hot or whatever yeah and then she
just walks up and she was like yup you
bet like peace okay and then she keeps
walking and i was like i tried to punch
him and her boyfriend was just like oh
yeah that's fine oh yeah just kept
walking aren't they married
okay i don't i don't even know who knows
these days but you know if you're
if you're that guy you're probably not
the most
alpha
you're not going to her husband or
husband boyfriend yeah you're not going
to be the one yeah knight in shining
armor so he just basically kind of ran
away and then she got up to the top of
the stairs and then
pretended to be this big victim yeah but
you think lady you were just making
jokes about it and you know you were
kind of joking around with him but still
all of that said
no come on man you gotta you gotta yeah
you gotta be a gentleman i agree and
understand i i agree with and understand
what he's trying to do in the sense that
he's like okay these politicians and
journalists and city council members
which is what he does he trolls all
these people they take themselves so
seriously and they think that they're so
important and he basically goes and
makes them look like the fools that they
are i can appreciate that
i love when he goes to city councils but
am i going to
endorse am i going to co-sign like you
know basically cat calling or harassing
a politician about her body parts that's
just not my brand yeah but there it is
kind of a debate between
what some people are calling you know
bar stool conservatism kind of like
raucous raunchy conservative south park
conservatives and they used to call it
and uh
like conservatism conservatives and i
just think
there are different candidates they're
different camps yeah not my speed all
right so we both got it right we both
got it right yes
all right
uh you read the next question okay
let's see
in general women are most happy in the
kitchen making homemade sourdough bread
sourdough bread specifically sourdough
bread is excellent and it's it's like
the easiest one i think that's how the
millennial hipsters are getting into it
in general in general
yeah i'm going to go with
yes
of course can we i know you're not
allowed to say it yeah
yes women generally speaking are happier
uh being the hand that rocks the cradle
is the hand that rules the world ruling
over the private home economy and the
life of their family than they are at
the widget factory for mr smith some man
who doesn't care about them such that
they the woman has to go out to work for
the guy so the guy can pay her family so
that the husband can pay some other
woman to raise their kids it doesn't
make any sense yeah no i would agree
with you i don't like sourdough brad so
that's the only issue that i would have
with this but if that is representative
of kind of running the home and being
home with your children that doesn't
mean that a woman doesn't have any
calling outside the house or that she
can't work or that she can't do other
things but her main priority and main
source of fulfillment coming from her
house and her husband and her kids yes
no matter what the feminists say that is
a more satisfying life it's just you're
just making a descriptive statement it's
not you're not even saying this is how
things should be you're just saying
that's the way it is there was a debate
once between betty friedan the american
feminist and simone de beauvoir the
french feminist who was the trumpet of
jean-paul sartre and that the debate was
over this very question should women be
allowed even to stay home and betty
friedan said look women should be
allowed to go work and they should be
allowed to stay home and simonda bevoir
said no
they cannot be allowed to stay home with
the kids if they are given that option
they will take it yeah uh oh maybe we
should just drink i'll drink anyway yeah
yeah to sourdough bread or a nice jewish
rye a dark blue anything
okay okay your turn
the wording is important here if i were
betting today i would take the field
any other candidate democrat or
republican over donald trump being
president in 2024
[Music]
okay
okay explain your reasoning
well on why i think you would answer
that way because it's the reasoning that
i have
i'm i'm afraid
i'm wrong yes because
donald trump is the best president of my
lifetime i think he did a marvelous job
i think he is
he's responsible for overruling roe v
wade i would vote for him again tomorrow
in a heartbeat without any not a
second's hesitation
i just don't think that they're gonna
let him be president again i think that
the libs
shut down the entire country and and
forced us all to lock down and changed
all the voting laws
pretty much just to get him out of
office in 2020 and i just don't think
that entrenched interests throughout the
government the corporate sphere
international interests just
just the the liberal establishment
broadly i just don't think they're going
to let that guy be president again even
if
the
majority of people in enough states
wanted him to
see my answer was no
so you're incorrect although i do think
that you're persuasive i do think that
you're persuasive in your reasoning i do
think that he is probably more motivated
and perhaps perhaps this might be
wishful thinking organized and perhaps
mobilized now that he saw how the last
election went and the powers that be
that really tried to place an obstacle
in front of his
victory and that's not a conspiracy
theory
it was the fairest election ever and no
i'm not even talking about fraud i am
talking about it everything in addition
or outside of that you mean like how
pennsylvania violated its own state
constitution i mean
a million different things or how time
magazine ran that long article saying
here's how he stole the election yeah
here's how we made sure that donald
trump didn't win and so i'm not sure if
i were betting today that i could say
that
now do i want donald trump to be
president that is a different question
i don't know you don't know you're
undecided
uh well i think let the best person win
do you have a favorite
um i do
isn't this person public i feel like
we're in middle school so who do you
like you know
um yes uh this person is is public so i
do have a favorite but i'm not just
closing yet okay
we'll see all right
does he live in florida i guess actually
two of them live in florida yeah we do
not i do not know i don't i don't know
is it liz traney it's liz james it is
i'm so sorry i can't believe that you
outed me as a rhino do we both drink
yeah we do
you're up
all right next question
there is a greater than 50 chance
beyonce and jay-z are practicing occult
numbers
a greater than 50 percent chance
for sure it's like i don't even think
that's yeah i mean i could have you
could have done 75 there and i still
would have said yes did you see that
that beyonce video xo
where it was some song i guess and in it
she just flashes a picture of a demon
for for a split second but just
completely out of nowhere it's not not
to do with the plot and it's just a
demon and uh yeah of course did you see
that people got mad at her because in
her latest album she said the word spazz
and they said that that's ableist and so
she took it out not to mention she says
like the n word and all these other
things that's totally fine but she said
spaz the the uh stanza in which spaz is
located in that song is about
this guy just having extremely graphic
vivid disrespectful sex with this woman
and even the word is like spazzing on
that you know took us and uh anyway you
think like that's the problem with this
is that yeah the symbolism right yeah
which it also doesn't make sense because
whoever wrote the lyrics to that song is
obviously extremely mentally deficient
so i don't even know how it could be
very true very true but yes i think that
they are probably at cold members i
think that's probably accurate uh or is
it your goal or my goal
okay
astrology the s super quote queer
science of kings according to yahoo news
and manifesting
are entirely demonic and should be
banned from all publicly funded
institutions and locations oh we know
this yeah we know the answer to this
uh-huh
yeah i didn't know that it had public
funds
yeah nor did i
we sure can we get a producer check on
whether it probably does i mean if
they're going to translate a lot yeah
yeah it's definitely demonic of course
you know it's so funny because the libs
and the squishes and the materialists
they always say astrology you shouldn't
do astrology because it's so dumb it's
so dumb and not real at all and i think
you know
yeah you shouldn't do astrology the
reason why is not that it's not real the
reason is that it is real and that's
what the bible doesn't say don't consult
astrologers because it's a waste of your
time yeah it's because it compromises
your free will and their witches yeah
yep exactly right so if my tax dollars
are going to that i want it to stop i
want it to stop no more manifesting okay
more on that in just a second first
though big tech is more powerful than
most countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data it's time
to put a layer of protection between
your online activity and big tech that
is why i use expressvpn think about how
much of your life is on the internet
sadly every site you visit every video
you watch every message you send gets
tracked and data mined when you run
expressvpn on your device the software
hides your ip address something bigtech
can use to personally identify you so
expressvpn makes your activity harder to
trace and sell to advertisers expressvpn
encrypts 100 of your internet data to
keep you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers on your network what i
like most about expressvpn is how easy
it is to use you download the app on
your phone or your computer you tap one
button boom you're protected it's easy
expressvpn does all of this without
slowing your connection that's why it's
rated the number one vpn service by
techradar the verge and countless others
stop handing over your personal data to
the big tech monopoly that mines your
activity and sells your information
protect yourself with the vpn that i
trust to keep me safe online
expressvpn.com
michael yt head on over there right now
get three months for free
are you ready i don't really follow the
rules
the midterms will likely be just a red
wave and not a tsunami
i agree with it because of the senate
map yeah the senate map is not
advantageous to republicans
you know only a third of the senate is
up at any given election year and
sometimes it's easier races sometimes
it's harder races and so because of that
i think it'll just be more likely a wave
than a tsunami but if you took that out
if it were just a kind of
all bets were even on the senate i think
it would be a tsunami well we haven't
even gotten our september october
surprise yet yep so something is
definitely coming down the pipeline
that's supposed to hurt republicans i'm
not sure if the abortion sentiment will
take us there but maybe i'm seeing a lot
of people even within my circles really
believe the lies about oh you can't get
treatment for a miscarriage and ectopic
pregnancies i don't know though that
that would make or break the election um
i think what worries me is that
democrats don't seem to care that the
midterms are coming up they're passing
you know the inflation enhancement act
as i think thomas massey called it
um
and so that is what troubles me that's
what troubles me they seem to think that
they have it in the bag no matter what
yeah yeah that and the fact that they
keep
pushing the widespread mail in ballots
the election day turns into election
month i mean all of that creates huge
vulnerability for fraud as barack obama
said
ten years ago or so so
they keep pushing that they're trying to
bring back covet i think we're on the
phi beta kappa variant now and they gave
us monkey box gosh they gave us monkey
pox in july
right what are they going to give us in
october yeah i can't even imagine yep
and so i think we both got that right we
did okay i'll drink to it
okay
i am close friends with someone who has
pronouns in their bio their bio notice
that run in there
close
yeah no no no no if i were close to them
they would have already been confronted
and
something would have happened they
probably would have stopped being
friends with me or they would have taken
it out of their profile hasn't happened
yet has it happened yet if it does
happen
i do have
some relatives or you know
friends or relatives of friends that i
will socialize with who have the
pronouns in bio yeah but i don't
i don't have any close friends
or at least people who would call me a
close friend
even if i were attempting to call them a
close friend who who have that yeah
other than you know the typical
conservative
his his majesty you know yes sir that's
right right i did have plenty of friends
that put the black square up ah the
black square do you know what i did for
black square day
i put the black square
with a rainbow in the middle and i just
asked i said what which liturgical month
are we in in the liberal calendar
that was that was confusing that was
june 3rd i remember very well
i don't know i put the little lucky
charms leprechaun up once time because i
don't i just
we try to keep up but we just can't yeah
the black square one was really annoying
too
i actually had actual friends of mine
write to me and say michael
you can't make fun of the black square
yeah see that was a different issue yeah
that was really difficult even like for
christians and christians who i know
voted for donald trump the same year
they really felt like they needed to put
a black square i i was very dismayed
many of my evangelical friends
and the evangelicals i counted on the
evangelicals they were very rockwood for
a lot of issues right
george floyd
did a lot of damage to the evangelicals
they just they i don't know what it was
i know well we're still actually feeling
the repercussions of that which is
something i talk about a lot it's
probably the thing that i get the most
flock for i probably got more
blow back from my stance on the whole
george floyd police brutality systemic
racism stuff in the summer of 2020 than
i ever have about trans or gay or any of
that stuff yeah because this is the
issue that even if christians feel that
they're conservative and biblical on
that well we can be conservative on that
but on the justice stuff maybe the
secular world really is right yeah and
i'm just like
they're wrong about literally everything
yeah but maybe on this day they've got
it
yep that's where the evangelicals went
wrong unfortunately
okay my turn this time
if the west is saved through a miracle
and or revival the next great clash
will likely be between catholicism and
protestantism
so the west is saved that will be the
next clash
correct
do you know why incorrect incorrect you
say
yeah okay why do you say no
um because of something that you
mentioned earlier about barstool
conservatives and that crowd that will
be
and not just them but also against the
unwoke liberals that are in our midst
who
who just want america go back to go back
to 1995
who really have no basis for why they're
against transgenderism for example but
they're for everything else that's going
to be the next battle i think catholics
and evangelicals will probably be
linking arms on that
it'll be a long time i think before
catholics and protestants have it out
that'll be a fun fight like i'm looking
forward to that we got a lot of work to
do even if the west is safe that is true
because you think of the sort of
non-woke liberals you know who and and
very often they're saying look i'm
totally fine with transgender leninism
but i am absolutely opposed to
pedophilic maoism
wait uh yeah can we go a little further
maybe
then yeah yeah i think that's true
tocqueville makes a provocative claim in
democracy in america
he says that america will end up
this very protestant country will end up
catholic
or not christian at all interesting what
do you think his reasoning is
i think his reasoning is that
protestantism is intrinsically unstable
so and you see it in the proliferation
just like democracy like democracy
actually yeah and
yeah
yeah there's no it's more complicated
with democracy well yes but it is the
democratization of christianity is what
the reformation was and
having individuals who are self-ruled
that is inherently unstable unless you
have some kind of shared guiding
principle and belief in something
transcendent so that's probably what
he's getting to is that there is kind of
um a central hold in catholicism
that evangelicalism doesn't or
protestantism
we would say that it's the gospel but
it's not institutional so interesting
right so that's his prediction and we've
got a long way to go but we have a lot
and that'll be a that'll be a fun battle
when we get there but i do have to drink
because i got it wrong yes you don't
i'll i'll just for camaraderie i'll
drink too
my turn yeah okay
let's be honest the trouble the trouble
all started when women were allowed to
vote
wow
hmm
you got it wrong you got it wrong i
didn't yes you did and that is because i
do think that there have been a lot of
problems with women being able to vote
absolutely but it
started a lot earlier than that it
started with a woman being deceived by a
snake that's where it started you know i
was gonna i was gonna say you've got to
go back to i don't know the 17th
amendment women voting is 19th uh direct
election of senators 17th that was kind
of a problem you know there were but no
you go back
i go back all the way so i mean the
problem is still in some ways with women
yeah um
but yeah the 19th that's just a symptom
of original sin
right
so i mean it is the election of the
apple okay because if you had one vote
per household that would have made sense
in a world in which everyone was getting
married but with feminism the
disintegration of the family that didn't
make sense anymore so really does go
back to yes no that's a great point and
it you know by the way one vote per
household
it
is a very compelling political idea
because the the implication of it is
that the family is the fundamental
political institution so by the way you
know if a woman is a widow or something
then she's she's that of her household
yeah
and these days there are so many soy boy
beta [ __ ] that i'm sure there are a lot
of women who would be the head of
household anyway yeah but the the real
difference is the individual versus the
family is the political unit i don't see
how you can be a conservative
and
think that the individual is the
fundamental political unit rather than
the family i don't it's just that that
is people who call themselves
conservative that do not think that the
natural family is the foundation of
conservatism that's a whole other
country right you're michael knowles
you're right you're right shall we drink
okay yeah i guess were we both wrong we
were both wrong but
i guess but there was a deep brightness
yeah laying beneath our wrong answers my
turn
anyone who performs gender affirming
surgeries on minor should be sentenced
to significant prison time and the
parents who signed off on it should also
serve jail time even if the children
might have to be placed in the foster
care system
[Music]
yeah you don't get to mutilate kids and
then keep your kids it's like the
definition of child abuse yeah i would
yeah they might have good intentions
yeah but i would say that hopefully just
like in any
in any case where there's child abuse
hopefully they can be sent to family
members before the foster care system i
would not like them to be in foster care
i do not want that for any child i think
that that is added trauma
but also if you have parents that are
like yeah you're 12 years old let's cut
off your healthy breasts or like let's
castrate you okay i'm not sure that you
are in an environment that is stable
anyway you're already enduring a lot of
trauma and they're about to push you
into inducing physical or
into enduring physical trauma too
usually irreversible that gives you
osteoporosis when you're very young
makes you sterile yeah i mean the
stories that i've heard of women who are
like hey i'm 25 i transferred when i
transitioned when i'm 16 and i can't
breastfeed even though i want to that
breaks my heart so there have there have
to be some kind of consequences for that
yeah and there there would be before you
get to the foster care system there
actually would be
steps along the way you know there would
be other options hopefully but yes i
think you're right yeah harsh but fair
yes okay your turn
holding political prisoners from january
6th in solitary confinement is worse or
equivalent to japanese people being held
at internment camps in the 1940s so i'd
like to add a little addendum to this
okay you know italians were held in the
camps too in america the internment
camps and they only talk about the
japanese people being held in the camps
but the italians were held here as well
no respect so we're talking no respect
for the italian the most aggrieved
monarchy you know the largest mass
lynching in american history you know
who the victims were italians italians
that's right 11 of them in 1891 year
before the first columbus day and they
did columbus day just to make the
italians feel better wow they don't no
one talks about it's anti-italian
discrimination it is it is we just
appropriate your pasta yeah that's right
don't even recognize your sacrifice no
respect so
so i'm definitely going to guess that
this is a yes for you
yeah for sure
yeah yeah obviously yeah i mean in some
ways i i mean can i say in some ways
that it's worse i mean solitary
confinement for anyone that's i mean
that is like one of the cruelest
punishments that you can endure as a
person plus you're you know when you're
talking about the i'm not like defending
world war ii in tournament but we are
talking about foreign nationals in many
cases we're talking about foreign
nationals from enemy countries who are
coming to america who are not citizens
who are you know who are being uh looked
at as potentially uh enemies of the
state after a major attack on it
unconstitutional it's not this they were
not placed in solitary confinement they
were not placed in solitary in some
cases when we're talking about january
6th we're talking about people
who we're not violent and they're being
put in solitary confinement so yep
yep correct correct okay
okay it's my turn
woke pastors and priests are actually
the most dangerous group of people in
the country the most
most dangerous
i don't know gotta think about that
you're correct
you were incorrect incorrect so okay we
agree yeah because
when the libs
burn and pillage and loot and everything
you know you you expect that and we can
stand firm against it but when those
snakes
infiltrate church
and deceive the faithful and lead them
astray well let's not forget the people
often talk about the millstones passage
of the gospel as being about
abortion or something they're killing
babies but that's not what it's about
it's about scandal it's about leading
people
is actually the word i think that's used
there
yes
you know you're exactly right that in
that passage for anyone who causes one
of these little ones to sin little ones
is actually christians it's not just
children
and they'll it'd be better for a
millstone to be tied around his neck and
thrown into the depths of the sea the
word that's used there for obstacle or
stumbling block is scandalizo which is
where we get the word scandal so you're
right when there's a scandal in the
church that causes people to sin
obviously
jesus took that really seriously so i
agree with you if only christians if
christians were the only
group in the country to stand firm on
all the issues that we talked about
whether it's gender or abortion or
marriage or whatever it is birth control
that would be enough that would be
enough to change the country but it's
because of squishy professing christians
that we are where we are yeah yeah yeah
the ones who make the conservative case
the conservative christian case for
transiting the kids and blm and all this
other stuff yeah it's empathetic
that's very good you think i mean the
blm people or the antifa or whatever
they can rob you of your life yeah the
the woke deceitful pastors they can they
can rob you of your salvation so true
okay uh
i'm up yes okay i think conservatives
should continue to exclude certain
right-wing people from their platforms
to stop controversial voices from
derailing momentum for example alex
jones now that complicates it
you're saying we should exclude anyone
at all
or only alex jones
because at this point the alex jones was
right jar is like overflowing on the gay
frogs and the you know global elites and
everything
well i think it depends i wouldn't
well i guess i can't say
all right so we so we'll we'll say let's
take alex that's an example but
conservatives should continue to exclude
any
right-wing
who
from platforms
the question being either you just let
on anyone who's
on the right or you have some limits
[Music]
yes
now that doesn't mean that i think that
they shouldn't be on twitter but when i
think of platforming them i think of
like my own platform like am i going to
have them on my show there are some
there are some limits i'm not talking
about alex jones but there are some
people who will call themselves right
wing that i wouldn't platform because i
just think their views are garbage and i
don't not that i don't agree with them i
just don't think they're even worth
consideration
but i still think even the worst ideas
political ideas anyway should be allowed
on places like twitter
you still think they should be allowed
okay i disagree a little bit in that
i don't i don't think that people have a
some right to say whatever they want or
you know i think free speech has limits
oh did you you should write a book i
would consider writing a book about it
yeah i uh but
and of course i think because of that i
have no problem excluding certain people
if i think you know their views are
abhorrent yeah whether they call
themselves right-wing or left-wing or
whatever um but i think that
i think we should
shift the overton window dramatically to
the right yes the overton window right
now and what is acceptable to talk about
is way way too far to the left i think
practically speaking we would not
exclude
virtually any right-wing voice i mean i
think we should shift it very very far
to the right in terms of and exclude the
people more people on the left yeah yeah
and
frankly even people today who would be
called centrist i mean i think they are
so far to the left frankly they should
be excluded
ultimately but in terms of alex jones i
don't know they always make alex jones
the poster child of this the guy was
right on the gay frogs he was right on
the global pedo networks he's he's you
know said some things that are pretty
kooky and out there but yeah and he's
also an entertainer who rips his shirt
off and sells vitamins but i just think
like he's the guy you're gonna ban why
so if you had a social platform all
these conservative social platforms are
all about like free speech we don't
censor but if you were to start a
platform
what would you censor
besides the truly like objectively
grotesque stuff but talking like
political opinions yeah well i i think
there's a business question which is how
do you grow a platform and i think
actually now it's virtually impossible
outside of twitter facebook and google
because yeah they got market dominance
on false pretenses and fraud and so i
actually i just generally speaking i
don't think you can really compete
period but even if you could what would
i be willing to censor uh bad stuff
i would say but now i i'm broadly for
toleration because i think it can be
beneficial to people to see different
points of view but
i don't think people have a right to
spout their nonsense i mean i would i
would certainly ban obscenity and porn
and all sorts of stuff and i would have
no problem even banning certain opinions
that are absolutely abhorrent yeah like
children should be able to transition
yeah that stuff's gone i mean yeah you
know i'd definitely get rid of that you
just think i mean there are always
limits on this stuff in the 50s you'd
say you know if you talk communism in
school you'd be fired and probably
sent to saint helena yeah and uh today
if you don't teach communism in school
you know if you teach christianity in
school gosh you'd be you'd be sent away
so there are always limits and i just i
would say what what should we that's
what the limits yeah what the limits are
and what should we limit uh bad stuff
what should we encourage good stuff yeah
it works for me yeah okay got it cheers
to good stuff yeah i would vote for you
stop it come on
i would and a heartbeat
um all right
oh this is perfect
low-rise jeans are a tool for
[Laughter]
low-rise jeans are a tool for
sexualizing you
for sexualizing youth and promoting
marxist minimalist ideology
wow
i thought they should have no place in a
healthy society
i thought you initially had said because
where you laughed i thought you said
low-rise genes have are a way of
sexualizing you
which is might be true
my future is so there is
in promoting marxist minimalist ideology
they should have no place in a healthy
society marxist minimalist yeah i don't
i don't know utilitarian i don't know
no they obviously they are meant to
sexualize the youths and everything and
arouse the prurient interest and you
know the base desires and things like
that but it's it's not marxist when i
think of marxist
minimalist you know tanky comrade stuff
i think of totally gray sweatsuits like
bertolt brecht or something okay jeans
have a kind of uh
ornamentation to them you know the
little that little button on the pocket
that serves really no purpose anymore
that's that you don't need that any you
know the kind of nice stitching so it's
not
my problem is the minimalism not the
sexualization okay i'm gonna go with yes
so you are incorrect on that so
unfortunately you're gonna have to drink
um
but that's just because i will take any
opportunity to slander
low rise jeans they're bad
they're ugly everyone looks bad in them
i actually my problem with it also as my
problem is with a lot of things these
days is that this generation has never
created like an original fad or style or
form of music it's all appropriation
from things when like we were little so
2000s 90s even 80s that's all they're
doing they don't have any originality
because they don't read books they don't
have culture all they do is look at you
know things when we were cool that's why
low rise jeans are back but they're ugly
ugly and so if i have to associate that
with karl marx dog on it let's do it i i
tell you if i if i had my brothers
i prefer the high-waisted there you go i
do yeah i do i bet your wife appreciates
that once you've had a couple kids too
it helps keeps it tight you know
yeah yeah exactly okay so we both drink
yep all right
okay
uh i'm up it's your turn okay
women
women should not speak in church
sort of devious smile from ellie
you're incorrect okay
um
because i do not think that women should
be preachers or pastors or
give the sermon
um on sundays but do i think that they
should not speak at all like they can
say hello like they can yes
yes they can you know give announcements
and things like that i think that they
can sing in church but they cannot
exercise authority over a man in church
which means they can't be pastors or
preachers or things like that
so paul does say that a woman should be
silent in church i do think in context
and in light of other things that he
said he really is talking about
exercising authority from scripture over
men and church so that's where i stand i
agree and i use the same sort of
technical distinction there yeah
obviously no no priestesses no
deaconesses no
alter servers or oh my gosh they do this
thing now in the catholic church ever
since vatican ii it was really after
vatican ii they redid the mass which
they didn't
need to do but a bunch of libs went in
and tried to destroy the beautiful
liturgical tradition of 2000 years and
uh
one thing they did is they have
extraordinary ministers of the eucharist
which inevitably is some liberal woman
wearing birkenstocks who is very
irreverently and disrespectfully holding
our lord in the eucharist and it's just
it's it's a complete abuse and so
obviously none of that should should be
encouraged yeah um but
you know if you have a wonderful
carmelite sister uh praying the rosary
sort of quietly and in a chapel or in
the church i mean i guess you're
speaking then yeah that's beautiful that
should be encouraged right and men and
women are called to prophesy in
scripture not depends on if you're
continuationist or cessationist but
prophecy can also be forth telling not
just foretelling so
there is also that conversation too
which we probably don't have time to get
into but anyway we agree you know we
have plenty of time to talk about no
you're right we'll have to save that for
the next episode all right
a chemical imbalance is totally fake and
is as scientifically sound as the people
saying they are big boned when they
can't lose weight
well that's easy yes
i'll say yes my only thought is some
people are kind of big boned my only
problem is with the last part of it
which is yes
fat people sometimes say that are you
saying that you have never seen the bill
nye the science guy episode you didn't
watch that in six months i am saying
that yes because i remember when we
watched an episode on that in sixth
grade and he said everyone's bones are
about the same size and i thought of a
girl in my class i'm like whoa i've
always thought that she was big bone and
really she's just fat
what about
what about like samoan people
you know they're all gigantic like that
ukulele player they're just a little fat
they're just fat they're just a little
fat i mean i think you can maybe be
broad but i don't think your bones are
your bones are just roughly the same as
everybody else yeah you just i used to
call it when i was little because my
parents told me i couldn't call my
preschool teacher fat i came up with the
term gathered out
so some gathered out yes they were
amazed that i came up with that phrase
but i did so some people are just
gathered out
so bones same size so chemical imbalance
i knew what you thought about that yeah
that's totally chemical imbalancing is
so ridiculous because this is what they
do the same libs who say that your
little boy is actually a girl and the
libs who said that we need to lock down
all the churches but not the pot shops
for kovid they're the same ones who say
and who say don't stop going to the gay
orgies for monkey pucks they're the ones
who say and by the way the only reason
you're sad in our decadent ridiculous
culture is because of chemical imbalance
hey buy our pfizer products you know
every single week it's ridiculous yeah
very true day two let's drink anyway
okay
speaking of altering our chemicals all
right yeah
opposition democrats used ray epps and
many federal assets to instigate a riot
on january 6th under a modern day
version of co-intel pro also the pipe
bomber was probably hunter biden
quit now hold on before you answer
there's so many different parts before
you answer due to youtube rules make
your guess but do not verbally confirm
if the other person guessed correctly
give only an amber ambiguous non-verbal
confirmation so i'm going to read that
first part again opposition democrats
used ray epps and many federal assets to
instigate a riot on january 6 under a
modern day version of
cointelpro also the pipe bomb was was
probably underbite
we'll just drink
all right you're up okay
within the confines of monogamous
traditional marriage which is totally
fine
to engage in adult activities
that some people may consider kinky
hmm
this is not fit for the queen this kind
of questioning um
correct i think we can just leave it at
it depends it depends right
it depends on what it is
some things are okay some things are not
okay
right
define our terms which we will not do
which we will not this is a family show
this is a family show but if we were to
define our terms i think we would say
there are some limits
yeah but we would at least say there's
some limits there that's not under
question the only question is if
you're right yeah we'll leave it at that
okay okay
string
okay so i think that's your
bunch of degenerate producers right in
these questions with grief i thought
your producer was a christian yeah
that's why i i was never under such a
misapprehension about him
i'm not saying monkey pox is completely
avoidable i'm just saying that it is as
easy as avoiding watching captain marvel
sure there's a chance of being t-boned
by a semi-truck causing you and your car
to crash into a theater while the movie
is playing however that's also still
more likely to happen than me
participating in gay origin who writes
this
maybe he was drinking as he was
certainly they've gotten crazier and
crazier so so i guess the prompt is
is it is more likely
that a t-bone truck would hit my car
sending me into a movie theater to watch
captain marvel then that i would
contract monkey bucks
by the way that people contracted
yes i think that we guessed
correctly i was talking to a woman on
the plane yeah who i think was probably
your typical
liberal white woman
she was saying just as i've gotten over
just as she's gotten over her paranoia
for kovid she now feels like she has to
worry about monkey jokes you know i said
you know i don't know you very well but
i'm i'm pretty confident that we don't
have to worry about that i think it's
excluded to one
demographic and she was shocked and i
was like i don't want to get into it
with you but
i'm confident it it you maybe you've
only been listening to cnn and you think
this is for everybody for everyone it's
not well actually nbc has been more
accurate about the risk than fox news
that's true that's true there was a
whole panel on it was on fox business
three three out of four people on the
panel
they said it's it two of them said it's
bigotry
to
say that you get monkey boxing gay
orgies and then the third guy was also
opposed to saying it's it's a gay word
she thing and it was only one guy one
out of four dead ryan holding down the
floor that ryan holding down the fort
lewis called a bigot for it that's
really amazing
yeah that yeah i think we're we're
marked safe from monkey box yes for now
that's good that's something to
celebrate definitely we can drink to
that
i wish i had been marked safe from
captain marvel i had to watch that
stupid movie never seen it
i have never seen a marvel movie or
avengers is that different i don't know
that no i i don't know if that is
different i can tell you it's it's worse
than monkeybox it's oh wow it is okay
thank you for coming on the show thanks
for having me we'll see you next time
[Music]